Speaker 1: Georgia is potentially going to
elect.
Herschel Walker.
Herschel Walker doesn't live in Georgia and
it is now becoming even more clear because
of an audio recording that has been resurfaced.
So let me give you the back story on this
and then I'm going to play a very important
clip for you.
One of the things we've known about Herschel
Walker, a former football player running as
a Republican for senator in Georgia against
the incumbent Democratic Senator Raphael Warnock.
The runoff is on December six and we will
have live results for you next Tuesday.
One of the things that we learned about him
is that he really has lived in Texas for a
while, but he claimed that he also lived in
Georgia.
And we are aware of a property that Herschel
Walker has in Georgia.
But now, due to a combination of new reporting
and a resurfaced audiotape, we have learned
that he doesn't really live in Georgia.
He admits that he lives in Texas, at least
he did a few months ago.
And also the property in Georgia was up until
recently rented out.
So he couldn't possibly be living there.
Yes, he owned a property.
He had an address where he could say, this
is my house, but he didn't live there and
it was, in fact, rented out to somebody else.
So let's go through this piece by piece.
First and foremost, we have this new admission
from Herschel Walker.
The Guardian is reporting about it.
I live in Texas.
Herschel Walker speech ads to Georgia Senate
Run Problems.
In a campaign speech earlier this year, Herschel
Walker, the Republican candidate, said, I
live in Texas.
I live in Texas.
Let's go to that audio.
It's not the best quality audio, but I think
we're not going to have a problem making it
out.
Speaker 3: When they asked me, why did I run
for a Senate seat?
Because to be honest with you, this is never
coming out.
Ever, ever, ever.
And I'm it's true.
But I was sitting in my home in Texas.
Speaker 1: I saw.
Okay, I was sitting in my home in Texas.
That doesn't mean he doesn't also live in
Georgia.
Okay.
But so that's a start.
Speaker 3: Let's continue in my home in Texas.
And I was seeing what was going on in this
country.
You know, I lived in Texas.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I went down to the border and I live in Texas
and I went down to the border.
This is in the context of running for Georgia
Senate.
And he says, I live in Texas and I went down
to the border.
Now, of course, he thought that it made sense
strategically to tout his bona fides about
knowing what's happening at the border.
The problem is you claim to live in Georgia,
but you say, actually, I know about the border
because I live in Texas.
And then and it just keeps coming.
We learned yesterday Herschel Walker's Georgia
home is a rental property.
The route reporting via Yahoo News.
Herschel Walker, his most recent scandal is
actually an old one going all the way back
to his campaign announcement last year.
It's been reported that Walker actually didn't
live in Georgia, the state he wants to represent,
at least not full time.
He owns a house in suburban Dallas that he
and his current wife occupied for years.
And Walker receives a homestead tax exemption,
which is reserved for a person's primary residence.
Hmm.
But Walker has always had an ace in the hole
to use for plausible deniability.
He still owns a house in Georgia.
A campaign finance report last year values
the house between 20 and $500,000 as long
as it exists.
Walker can rebut his critics with the fact
that plenty of people own houses in more than
one state.
Now, a new report pokes holes in that idea
with receipts that until recently, Walker's
Georgia home was occupied by renters who paid
Walker and his wife thousands.
And The Daily Beast has the specifics.
The house doubled as the Walker campaign's
official address when he launched his bid.
Records show it's owned by Walker's wife,
solely who was collecting rental income on
it.
It's his wife's house, and it at least was
until recently, rented out.
Herschel Walker was clearly not prepared to
deal with this issue in the way that Mehmet
Oz was prepared to deal with it.
Mehmet Oz certainly isn't from Pennsylvania,
but he was slightly more credibly able to
make the case that he's sort of from Pennsylvania
and lives in Pennsylvania.
He has more than two houses.
I don't even remember the number at this point
in time.
So Herschel Walker caught in another lie.
Now, quite frankly, I don't think this is
going to make a very big difference.
Right wingers will say Democrats are the devil.
I don't care where Herschel Walker lives,
it's better for the country and for the state
for Walker to be representing us rather than
Warnock.
And he could live in Alaska.
He could live in Timbuktu.
I don't really care.
But the race is expected to be relatively
close.
There's a lot of little things that have been
going against Herschel Walker.
And if this has even a very small impact,
it's now a growing list of things which hopefully
will give us the results that we want.
On Tuesday, we're going to be live with the
results.
On Tuesday, of course, starting.
You know, I actually don't know.
I think the polls close at eight in Georgia.
I'm going to double check that if indeed the
polls close at eight.
We'll probably be live at 7:30 p.m. Eastern
Time and then the results will start coming
in.
If I learn that the results won't even start
coming in until nine, maybe we'll start at
830.
But I will be live on YouTube, Twitter and
Facebook.
I hope that you will join me and we will have
all of the clips I played here today on our
Instagram, which you can find by searching
Instagram for David Pakman show.